today is april 2nd 2022
which means that for
muslims all around the world it is the
first day of ramadan
now ramadan as many of you probably know
is the annual month of fasting one of
the five so-called pillars of islam
alongside the five daily prayers
the sakat you know giving to charity as
well as the shahada and the hajj or
pilgrimage to mecca so every year in the
month of ramadan muslims around the
world will fast for 30 days so for the
full month of ramadan what this means is
that muslims will abstain from food and
drink and yes that does include water as
well as sexual activity from the break
of dawn till sunset every day now this
is one of the central practices in islam
as i said it's considered one of the
so-called five pillars of the islamic
religion so it's one of the main
practices and the reason for this fast
and there are different of course
interpretations and and perspectives on
why
you fast but in general you could say
that one fast in order to get
closer to god through
controlling your base
desires and your appetites and through
that you're kind of purifying your soul
so that it can more easily
you know receive
blessings from god you could say fasting
is about turning away from the body and
turning towards god it's a conscious
effort to
choose god or the divine before one's
own desires and one's own needs in that
way it is to reorient one's
consciousness and one soul away from the
body and from the ego and instead focus
entirely on god and on the divine now
fasting in general is of course
a very widespread practice across
different religions all over the world
it's not something that is unique to
islam
fasting is one of the most common i
would say
spiritual techniques and practices that
have been used across history and in
different cultures and different
religions
you have you know in christianity you
have the fasting of great lent where you
fast also for a bit more than a month 40
days you have in judaism the fasting of
yom kippur and
various other
circumstances when the jews will fast
sometimes fasting can last for just a
few hours sometimes it's a few days
weeks a month etc but the general idea
remains the same to abstain from
usually food and sometimes drink
but it can also be
more specific so some fasts in
christianity for example it's it's
common to fast on fridays but what this
means is that one abstains from eating
meat and drinking alcohol so you will
eat vegetarian food or sometimes you eat
fish because in medieval times fish
wasn't considered meat
so that's one example of a more specific
fast in that way we have fast in
buddhism buddhist monks will
fast and abstain from eating to help
with meditation we have fast in hinduism
in the baha'i faith
in taoism so it's a widespread practice
across various different religions and
in islam it's given a very prominent
role as one of the five pillars of you
know obligatory fasting during the month
of ramadan and there can be differences
in
ideas behind why
one fast indeed these different
religions but
throughout all of it is the trend of
making a point of that there is a there
is a spiritual benefit to
abstaining from
things that we usually consume and to
sort of block off our desires in some
way which and food and hunger is of
course one of the main
things that we experience every day it's
a very central part of our lives that
when we don't eat we get hungry and
that's a very that can be a very strong
desire you want to quench that hunger or
quench that thirst by eating or drinking
and by fasting you're sort of
controlling that and through that your
you know those who practice fasting will
say that that
is an opportunity to purify
your soul or your your inner state now
you know fasting is also not unique to
religions many people fast for health
reasons without being connected to a
specific religion but in islam the
fasting is done essentially in order to
purify the soul to control one's base
desires and carnal desires in order to
get closer to god and this is a practice
that goes back to the very beginnings of
islam it is said that the prophet
muhammad and his companions would fast
during the month of ramadan it is also
mentioned in the quran for example so in
the second chapter of the quran surat
al-baqarah it says that
ramadan is the month in which the quran
was revealed as a guide for humanity
with clear proofs of guidance and the
standards to distinguish between right
and wrong so whoever is present this
month let them fast
so this verse of the quran refers to the
idea that the first night when the
prophet muhammad was given the first
revelation from god that became
the quran the first part of the quran is
known as the lailat al-khadr the night
of power and this was during the month
of ramadan and this is one of the main
reasons that this is a month
that has become very sacred
to muslims and in the islamic faith
and it's the reason at least partly the
reason why one fast during this month
according to the great scholar
theologian and mystic abu hamid al
ghazali when he talks about the fast he
defines it as quote the purpose of
fasting is the weakening of carnal
appetites and hunger as i said is of
course one of the most central of these
carnal appetites um and one that you
know if we would just listen to every
desire we had and consume
every bit of food we felt like eating
and and every piece of candy and and you
know that would just not be good for us
both physically and if you do believe in
in a kind of soul it probably isn't very
good for the soul either and that's what
what these thinkers are pointing to as
well so in islam and especially in
sufism there is talk of something called
the jihad enoughs the struggle against
the self or the ego and the ego is the
you could say the lower part of oneself
so
the idea of the the individual
self that is separated from everyone
else and this is the self that also has
desires like it wants to eat it wants to
have sex it wants to
have power and all these things and this
self or this ego can become very
powerful it can become very dangerous if
it isn't controlled if it isn't
you know kept in its place so to say
and this is especially in sufism there's
a great focus on on fighting against
this idea of the nafs of the self or the
soul and this is precisely the purpose
of fasting as well
by abstaining from food which is one of
those central desires that human beings
has that is a something that
the ego does not like at all and so by
controlling the ego by by not giving the
ego what it wants the soul becomes more
purified by you know being less ego and
more direct contact with god in some way
al-ghazali again writes quotes it is a
victory over iblees or the devil the
enemy of god most high for his armies
are the carnal appetites and fasting
defeats his armies because its true
nature is the abandonment of the
appetites about this the messenger said
quote again satan flows about inside a
person as blood does in the body thou
must make his passage difficult with
hunger
the great sufi mystic ibn adabi also
states about hunger more generally in
his treatise called hilayat abdal what
hunger is in every state in every
respect a means whereby the seeker and
the verifier can attain to a more
exalted degree for the seeker in terms
of spiritual states for the verifier in
terms of mysteries
hunger has a spiritual state and a
station it is characterized by humility
submission servility lack of
self-importance indigence discretion
tranquil emotions and an absence of base
thoughts this is the state that the
seeker has
so he indicates here that by
abstaining from these things by fasting
by being hungry
both
literally and in a more abstract
metaphorical sense we are cultivating
other aspects of ourself like lack of
self-importance like humility and that
becomes really important for one's
spiritual development and for reaching a
state that is more closely in line with
with the divine with god and these
consequences of fasting like humility
and lack of self-importance also leads
to other positive things of course in
relation to one's perspective on
on one's own position and on others who
are less fortunate so sometimes people
will say that the fast of ramadan is
essentially about feeling sympathy with
those who are less fortunate those who
are poor and cannot maybe don't have
access to food for example and while
that isn't necessarily the main reason
behind the fast that's definitely a very
important consequence and aspect of the
fast that is you know if you don't eat
and if you if you
cut off yourself from eating and you
become very hungry and you experience
that kind of that pain and that struggle
you will
automatically start to sympathize with
those who have to go through that and
don't perhaps have the security of being
able to break the fast whenever they
want so that's a very natural
consequence of
something like fasting that one gets a
better sometimes perspective on
those kinds of aspects of life and and
society in the future or the meccan
revelations the great compendium by the
mystique
he dedicates a full chapter to the
practice of fasting and the month of
ramadan in particular as one of the
aspects of this chapter and there he
writes very poetically quotes when the
gates of the fire are locked it turns
back on itself and its heat is
multiplied on it and it consumes itself
the person fasting is like that with his
nature when he fasts the gates of the
fire of his nature are shut
so what he's saying is that the the fire
or the hunger that a person feels is not
quenched when one closes the gates to
the fire so that it cannot be you can't
put water on it to make it go out this
means that the hunger or desire will
want to have something to to make it go
away but it won't get that relief so
instead it's going to eat itself up and
and sort of consume itself
and you know not go away of course but
in that way one starts to be able to
transcend hunger another phrase by even
arabic in the future
one transcends hunger one transcends
one's desires eventually um so that one
reaches a higher spiritual state now
important to point out is that there are
of course many rules surrounding how
the fast should be done when one can
break the fast what one is supposed to
do it's it's not just about
not eating as we will see soon and there
are of course exceptions when one
doesn't have to fast so sick people will
of course have to eat or drink so if if
you're sick you don't have to fast
during them if you're pregnant um
you
a lot of people will will not fast when
they're pregnant if people are traveling
uh and and especially back then you talk
about you know the middle ages for
example traveling meant going walking or
riding on a horse or something like that
for long distances and for that of
course you needed sustenance so in those
circumstances you didn't have to fast so
there are rules around that and not
everyone has to fast
if they can't fast for example but but
it is expected of every healthy
practicing muslim that he or she
should fast during this month but of
course as i said it isn't just about not
eating or just being hungry it is about
focusing more turning inwards and
focusing more on your religious duties
on
worshiping god and so on so for a muslim
during ramadan they will not just
abstain from eating and drinking and
having sex during the day they will also
try to not swear of course these things
should always be
you know a muslim should always try to
to avoid these things
but
during ramadan there's often a conscious
effort to be even more
careful with your behaviors or not swear
not talk behind people's back not
say things that are inappropriate not
just being a good person as much as
possible in the alchemy of happiness al
ghazali says quote so from this you
learn that the fast of whomever limits
his fasting to not eating and not
drinking is a soulless form for the
spirit
and true nature of fasting is that one
makes oneself like the angels for whom
there is absolutely no carnal appetite
the beasts are dominated by their
appetite and for this reason they are
far from the angels any person dominated
by appetite is also at the level of the
beasts when his appetite is decreased he
has begun to take on a resemblance to
the angels for this reason he approaches
them and approaching attributes not in
station and the angels are near god most
high consequently he is also near god
when he makes arrangements to attempt to
suffer and gives full aid to what the
appetite desires the appetite grows
stronger not weaker and the spirit of
the fasting is not obtained al-ghazari
also writes that quote it is to restrain
all of one's bodily limbs from
impropriety but it's not limited to the
stomach and the generals the perfection
of this fasting lies in six things first
to restrain the eye from looking at
things that distract them from god
especially from that thing which arouses
one's carnal appetite he then quotes a
hadith that says that the prophet
muhammad said quote five things break
the fast a lie slander table bearing a
false oath and a lustful glance
second to restrain the tongue from
foolish talk and everything that is
superfluous one should remain silent or
engage in the recitation of the quran
argument and disputatiousness are among
the harmful things as for slander and
table bearing according to the school of
some religious scholars even the fast of
the common fork is broken by them so
while the abstaining from food and drink
is the
outer most
clearly visible and main part of the
fast it is also about abstaining from
lying from swearing from all these other
aspects of one's life and instead that
one focuses on being a good person and
on your religious life so muslims will
often recite the quran or read the quran
even more so than otherwise and and do
prayers both the obligatory prayers of
course but also additional prayers and
really spend the month focusing
more than otherwise
on religion on god and on spiritual
development essentially fasting is you
could say a form of jihad a form of
struggle in the religion a struggle to
control your ego to control your carnal
appetites and to
cultivate a more pure
soul
that
is closer to god and and as i said also
another important results of fasting is
as ibn albert pointed out things like
feeling of humility of lack of
self-importance and that also leads to
feeling sympathy for the poor
and and other people who are less
fortunate there's a lot
of things that go in to something like
fasting and in particular in islam in
the month of ramadan and so for this
reason it's a very sacred and special
month to muslims
it lasts as i said for about 30 days it
is determined by the sighting of the
moon
because islam follows a moon calendar
that's different from our gregorian
calendar
and the islamic year because it follows
the moon calendar is of course shorter
than the gregorian calendar that is the
sort of standard around the world you
could say and so ramadan moves every
year so it moves back about
about two weeks so about 14 days or so
every year
and so some years
it will be in the middle of winter which
means that for people in up in
in the north in places like sweden the
hours when the sun is up is very few
likewise a few years later it will be in
the middle of summer which means again
here in the north it will be basically
no
time when the sun has set so that
creates problems and people solve this
in different ways some will follow the
the sun rise and sunset of
mecca or other places
and in in a general sense there are
different ways of solving this but so
it is determined by the signing of the
moon both when the month begins and when
the month ends so the beginning and end
of the month of ramadan can
it's a bit up in the air exactly when
it's supposed to end for example until
the so-called moon ciders
can confirm that the month has ended and
by the end of the month of ramadan there
is this great feast called edelfitter
which is the
the greatest you could say holiday of
the year in islam at least one of the
greatest holidays where one will often
gather as a family children will get
presents and families will eat together
celebrating that will not celebrate that
the month is over but celebrating
this beautiful month of fasting and
coming together in a celebration so
it's a really
beautiful tradition i would say it's a
very central part of the islamic
religion and one that is very important
and very dear to a lot of people around
the world as i said in the beginning
today is april 2nd 2022 which is the
official starting date for the month of
ramadan for at least most muslims around
the world so keep in mind if you know
muslims you have muslim friends or
family
maybe at your workplace for example that
for the next couple of weeks they might
be
extra tired because they are fasting but
now perhaps you know a little more about
what this month is about what this fast
is about and and so you can
maybe appreciate its long history and
the reasons behind this fasting to all
of my muslim friends out there who are
fasting i wish you a very happy and
especially meaningful ramadan i hope
this month of fasting is spiritually
uplifting and i wish you and your family
good health i hope this will be a very
meaningful and significant month for all
of you who are observing
thank you all for watching this short
and somewhat unusual video on this
channel
but because this was the start of this
month i wanted to do a little video that
talked about this significant part of
one of the largest religions in the
world
i will see you in the next video with
some very exciting topics that we'll be
talking about next week so very much
look forward to that for now
thank you so much
and take care
[Music]
you